joining us now with reaction to
tonight's opening monologue Florida
congressman Matt Cates Fox News
contributor Sarah Carter and Fox News
legal analyst Greg Jarrett I have a
source map that actually suggested to me
that is as shocking as this four-page
memo is going to be the foundational
information by which it was written it
almost it's gonna come on the heels of
it and it's gonna be like a slow drip
there are those that are saying release
at all
would that be a good idea that's what so
many of us have called for we believe
the memo should be released and that
supporting documentation that doesn't
reveal sources or methods should also be
available for the American people to
review but it's important to note Sean
this memo lays out facts these are not
opinions this is not conjecture these
are facts assembled by the Intelligence
Committee staff and then presented to
the members of that committee I have
every confidence that this will persuade
the American people that we've got to
make major changes in not only the
people that are currently in some of
these agencies of government but also in
the regulatory structure so that this
type of behavior never happens again but
if it's a document that fueled an
intelligence investigation during a
political campaign that's unverified
isn't that basically saying and devan
known as a statement that the dossier
bought and paid for by Hillary was
actually used to get a FISA warrant in
an election year against an opposition
party candidate I think my reading
comprehension is pretty good well Sean
as you know to answer that question with
particularity would violate the terms of
our non-disclosure agreement I can say
that I believe that many of the issues
that have been discussed in the public
can confirm I have good reading
comprehension skills can you confirm
that undoubtedly you demonstrate them
each and every night on television
all right Sarah Carter what we see
tonight to me is so transparent and
obvious rod Rosenstein wants to look
better he's scared to death and Peter
struck wants to look better why he's
even still working at the FBI is a
mystery to me
but you have sources tonight and you're
breaking some new information that's
right I mean it appears that there's a
concerted effort on the part of the FBI
members of the intelligence community
and the Department of Justice to try to
force the President to delay the release
of the memo and they're doing this in an
effort to buy time according to sources
that I've spoken with so that they can
leak information to try to find a way to
either discredit the memo or or placate
those members of the DOJ that don't want
to see this release Sean they are
terrified about the American people
finding out what's in this memo because
it does expose members of the DOJ
members of the FBI and others and
evaluating yet it names names and it
actually shows extensive FISA abuse this
needs to be made public the American
people have a right to see this and the
intelligence people have spoken with and
US officials who are familiar with this
memo
say this memo in no way violates the
intelligence community's standards as
far as disclosing anything that would be
related to national security I think you
have equally interrupt right there Sean
if people are trying to convince the
president not to release this memo
they're not going to be successful he
said on the floor last night when
Congress get a relation was pressing him
that he was going to release and he said
imagine what would happen if we didn't
so he knows the American people are
demanding it Gregg Jarrett I'm reading
Deven Eunice's memo back in response to
the FBI rod Rosenstein remember before
just within hours there was a they were
looking for these documents for a year
and just hours before the deadline it
was Rosenstein going begging pleading
with paul ryan don't release it the same
thing is going on today about the memo
here I assume you have the same reading
comprehension skills that I do and what
I'm reading is this is that the dossier
was used at least in part to get a FISA
warrant to spy on an opposition party
candidate in an election year and that
dossier was full of Russian lies paid
for by Hillary and that would be a crime
called deprivation of rights under color
of law punishable by 10 years you can't
use a false document to spy on some or
unverified but it is false and if they
alter the 302 forms the witness warms
well that's obstruction of justice look
Stein in the FBI must think everybody in
America is really stupid that they're
compounding their felony by trying to
cover it up at first you know the
pretense of all you're going to reveal
sources and methods they've now
dispensed with that fiction and and now
they're saying well it's omissions well
they're the ones who are responsible for
the emissions they've been trying to
obstruct a legitimate investigation by
congressman gates and others on Capitol
Hill which have oversight
responsibilities under the Constitution
Sarah Carter let's talk about the all
three of the 302 s because this came up
in the McNabb firing McCabe firing this
is beyond serious you have a reporting
on this can you share it tonight well
what we know is this and what I know is
this I've spoken to a number of sources
who have said that McCabe had actually
asked members of the FBI an FBI official
actually to alter the 302 whether the
302s those are the witness interviews
that the FBI conducts with the witnesses
and who do we want to alter well I don't
want to talk about that just yet until
we verify it but there was a one person
in particular that they believe McCabe
had asked the FBI agents to alter the
302s and I think this is significant it
doesn't mean that they altered the 302s
but even the fact that if they were
asked allegedly if this actually
happened that is a huge violation huge
violation Sean and it's what we're going
to be investigating because we're
running out of time
what you're saying is assuming we get
the memo tomorrow that means the day
after and that means next week and the
week after that we're going to find even
more abuse than what it is that I'm
talking about right oh absolutely and
and another very important question here
is when the warrant was issued who kept
reauthorizing the warrant over and over
again was there is there is a lot of
discussion that it was rod Rosenstein
who kept reauthorizing the warrants
based on false engagement that would
mean rod Rosenstein the guy that
appointed the special counsel Muller
could have extended a FISA warrant
without asking you to reveal anything
let's say that that's true doesn't that
mean that Robert Muller's investigation
was predicated on false information
based on a false FISA warrant Shawn this
is an issue where some Republicans
disagree I believe that the information
in this memo absolutely proves that the
Muller investigation is built on a
rotten foundation that the entire molar
probe is a fiction that it never should
have been started in the first place but
for bad acts and so that's my view and I
would suspect that most of the American
people would hold that view once they
read this memo all right released a memo
let